como lo decíamos se pronosticaba una ola
de migrantes en la frontera e incluso el
mismo presidente Joe biden dijo que
sería un escenario caótico pero hasta el
momento el flujo sigue siendo mucho
menor a qué cree que podemos atribuir
esto
Andrés Muchas gracias por la invitación
Bueno yo creo que es algo demasiado
temprano como para poder dar una
respuesta acerca de qué es lo que va a
suceder en las fronteras evidentemente
la ofensiva diplomática de información
que ya hemos empezado a mirar por parte
del gobierno norteamericano indicando de
que el título 42 ha terminado que se va
a implementar el título ocho y de que no
existen fronteras abiertas y de que la
mayoría que no cumple con los nuevos
requisitos van a ser expulsados o
deportados desde los Estados Unidos Es
evidente que eso va a detener por un
tiempo a esa gran masa migratoria que
está a la expectativa de qué es lo que
va a suceder yo creo que lamentablemente
no va a dar los frutos necesarios porque
no se están enfrentando los problemas
que originan la migración en la región
sino están queriendo solucionar con una
curita digo yo una a una enfermedad que
se necesita una cirugía y esa cirugía se
llama una reforma migratoria integral en
los Estados Unidos
ahora por un lado está el título ocho la
aplicación está móvil cpi One con la que
los migrantes pueden solicitar una cita
y también está la creación este proyecto
de creación de centros de procesamiento
en Guatemala y Colombia qué tan
efectivas hasta el momento pueden llegar
a ser esta Avenida estas medidas para
atender la situación migratoria
yo creo que son buenas intenciones por
parte del gobierno de la Administración
biden
obviamente los gobiernos de la región
van a apoyar porque supuestamente les
van a dar millones de dólares para
evitar la migración de sus ciudadanos
pero en realidad o en la práctica lo que
hemos visto Es que la aplicación del cbp
One es una aplicación que una que está
limitado a un cierto número de personas
y que los venezolanos los haitianos han
sido los que más se han quejado porque
no han podido utilizar en la forma o en
la magnitud que las autoridades están
indicando precisamente porque no no es
la la solución concreta existen apenas
30 mil visas mensuales que se van a dar
de ingreso a los venezolanos a los
haitianos a los cubanos a los
nicaragüenses Y eso prácticamente
se los puede
se los puede tener en un día por el gran
flujo de migrantes que están llegando
hacia hacia Estados Unidos ahora con los
centros de procesamiento que se va a
abrir en Guatemala y en Colombia Sí
parece que quieren expandir fronteras
virtuales de lo que se pretende hacer
pero a la larga yo creo que tampoco va a
funcionar eventualmente Esto va a ser
como un proceso de
visado actualmente todos los migrantes
que están en las fronteras podrían
solicitar visa Pero por qué nos las Por
qué no las solicitan porque hay un gran
número de personas que no califican y
que se las van a negar y ahora van a
presentar las solicitudes por medio de
cvp One y posiblemente tampoco les den
el asilo entonces eventualmente va a ser
una opción más para aquellos migrantes
que quizás en el futuro digan Oye ni
siquiera voy a perder el tiempo en
solicitar porque sé que no me la van a
dar Así que voy a tratar una vez más
esta vez ya no me entrego migración si
no voy a cruzar la frontera o lanzarme a
los mares o donde sea para entrar y si
es que me agarran pues me agarran o si
no vamos a ver cómo van a cuidar más de
tres mil kilómetros de frontera señor
Murillo En qué medida la migración se
instrumentaliza en el actual ambiente de
precampaña electoral en Estados Unidos
tanto por republicanos como por
demócratas
Andrés Mire es una vergüenza ajena es
una excusa Perfecta diría yo y es una
hipocresía por parte del gobierno tanto
de bairen como de los republicanos ambos
lados pretendiendo el uno ser El
Salvador y el otro ser el verdugo de
esta gran masa de migrantes que están en
Estados Unidos y que en la práctica lo
van a utilizar para una agenda política
de lado y lado los unos queriendo
aprobar una reforma migratoria Y de esa
manera ganar el gran flujo de votos
latinos y el otro
poniendo el miedo a la población
indicando de que los migrantes son los
malos de la película y eventualmente
ellos son los que van a cuidar las
fronteras y automáticamente todo va a
llegar a la normalidad ninguna de las
dos corrientes políticas Andrés tienen
en realidad un interés real de
solucionar esta problemática como lo
dije anteriormente han pasado más de 30
años y no hay una respuesta para tener
una reforma migratoria en los Estados
Unidos que ese sería el paso principal